[Musique]
le phénomène me touche tous les milieux
que ce soit artistique politique et même
plus récemment sportif le milieu de la
natation est son choc la semaine
dernière le nageur français yannick
agnel a été accusé de viol et
d'agression sexuelle sur une mineure de
moins de 15 ans la jeune femme qui
l'accuse et la fille de son ancien
entraîneur yannick agnel âgé de 9 ans de
plus à l'époque a reconnu ses actes
comme l'a déclaré ce matin la procureure
de la république de mulhouse yannick
agnel
reconnaît la réalité des faits qui lui
sont reprochés il explique que ces
rapports ont toujours été consentie il a
le sentiment effectivement de placer
cette contrainte pour la loi interdit
enfants toute relation sexuelle entre
majeurs et mineurs de moins de 15 ans
même si celui ci est consentant le
champion olympique a été mise en examen
et placés sous contrôle judiciaire et
ses contrats avec radio france ont été
suspendus alors après avoir reconnu les
faits comprenez vous que yannick agnel
soit encore en liberté
merci historienne à nous d'être avec
nous avocats merci beaucoup à yves soir
est ce qu'on peut dire que c'est une des
affaires les plus graves dans le milieu
du sport là c'est un truc de fou en plus
aujourd'hui on a entendu la déclaration
guennic agnel c'est fou cette affaire
c'est une affaire qui est très spécial
parce qu'on parle beaucoup d'agressions
sexuelles de viols présumés on a parlé
dans l'émission tout à l'heure j'ai
assuré arrivé à l'habitant également
ppda jean nucléaire ou encore nicolas
hulot mais là c'est très particulier
pour deux raisons la première c'est
qu'en fait aujourd'hui il a reconnu non
pas les faits mais la maternité en fait
il reconnaît avoir eu des relations
sexuelles à ce que certains vous disent
non il ya dix ans il ya 15 ans et à 5
ans là c'était en 2007 moi j'ai peu de
relations in i know clean du liban on ne
dit pas qu'elle n'était pas consentante
mais il n'y pas deuxièmement et surtout
on parle là d'une victime présumée qui
avait à l'époque 13 ans 13 ans c'est
très jeune et la loi faut le savoir
protège énormément les mineurs qui sont
violées et en particulier une sorte de
barre que mais la loi qui est à 15 ans
on estime que à un mineur de moins de 15
ans il faut le protéger énormément et la
loi et vient de changer au mois d'avril
donc cyril c'est toujours maintenant on
considère que un majeur
quelles relations sexuelles avec un
mineur qui a moins de 15 ans on
considère que mineur automatiquement il
n'était pas consentante même si oui mais
j'étais consentante automatiquement on
estime qu'il est trop jeune pour donner
son consentement éclairé comme une jeune
fille de 13 ans ne peuvent pas ne peut
pas être consentante mais bon au niveau
de la loi massé sa nouvelle adresse et
c'est important que
planifiez environ 0 il ya viol et
pourquoi on parle également de agression
sexuelle parce que les relations durer
plusieurs mois donc a eu des relations
sexuelles pénétrations donc violent
également des relations sans pénétration
donc c'est violent plus agression
sexuelle c'est ce qu'a retenu la
qualification en tout cas du juge et
puis une circonstance aggravante c'est
la répétition parce que la procureur l'a
bien dit les viols ont été commis alors
à mulhouse là où il s'entraînait à
l'époque en taille l'ambiance était quoi
en fait c'était ça c'était la fille de
nom mais en fait c'était quoi c'était
s'étaient ils sûrs tels que depuis 13
ans face à nous oui et lui dit gt ça
c'est dit qu'il était amoureux il dit il
il avait calé à
onze ans d'écart 13 1 2 4 et la poudre
et la procureure dit je retiens les car
vous l'avez dit mais aussi la répétition
parce que mulhouse en thaïlande à rio
antunes et des riffs nom qui a eu plein
d'endroits ils vivaient vivait une
histoire selon lui mais la loi dit que
non et au début de la garde à vue ils
étaient très réticents et puis la
plainte de la jeune fille qui date de
juillet extrêmement circonstanciés avec
l' enquête de la police judiciaire la
jeune fille aujourd'hui à la plage de la
19 ans j'avais 19 ans d'accord qu'est-ce
qui vous qu'est ce qui a fait qu'elle
est là c'est décidé selon la procureure
c'est la libération de la parole global
dans d'autres affaires qui a fait
qu'aujourd'hui elle ne s'est plus senti
sous emprise et qu'elle s'est libéré
qu'elle a parlé plainte avec des détails
très précis la police judiciaire enquête
et rapidement en août et puis après ça
s'est enchaîné jusqu'à la mise en examen
oui on m'a dit qu'elle se serait sentie
mal à partir de décembre 2020 qu'elle a
commencé à perdre du poids avant les
troubles du comportement alimentaire
peut t'aider hospitalisation et là ses
parents se seraient demandé qu'est ce
qu'elle a et effectivement la parole se
seraient libérés et d'où la plainte en
juillet 2021 valérie non mais c'est le
genre voulait revenir sur le fait
qu'entre j'ai entendu dire ils ont vécu
une histoire d'amour lui peut-être a eu
le sentiment de vivre une histoire
d'amour mais rappelons-nous vanessa
spring aura qui a écrit le consentement
qui qui est un livre où elle parle
justement de ça elle avait 13 ans elle
était avec gabriel matzneff qui était un
un grand écrivain reconnu par tout le
monde et elle disait à l'époque elle
qu'elle était amoureuse je suis
aujourd'hui elle dit mais non en fait je
me rendais pas compte parce qu'à 13 ans
on peut pas avoir de consensus mais j'ai
à présent c'est pas une histoire d'amour
égal et donc des parts elle avait été
violée alors est il il a reconnu les
faits oui alors il a reconnu ce qu'on
appelle la mater des faits donc les
relations sexuelles il dit lui qui se
souvient pas qu'il y avait une
contrainte morale qui devrait obliger
notamment parce que les faits se sont
multipliées sur de nombreux mois mais en
tout cas et c'est nouveau aujourd'hui il
dit oui c'est vrai je reconnais
parfaitement qui est des relations
sexuelles d'accord alors justement lors
là il est ici a reconnu les faits qui
suit va se passer pour lui parce que là
c'est vrai que c'est s'est passé les
faits sont pas prescrits la peine peut
être très très lourd d'un oui oui oui
parce qu'elle a été remis en liberté et
a mis en liberté sous contrôle
judiciaire draconien d'accord à ce port
laisser il ne peut pas quitter paris et
la petite couronne aucun contact avec la
famille de la jeune femme est bien
entendu la jeune femme
très précisément suivi etc lorsque la
fiction connerie tout compte selon son
papa le volant trailer de vienne pour
tout vous dire la procureure a dit
qu'elle n'a pas voulu remonter dans
l'antériorité familiale on ne sait pas
exactement ce qui s est back aux
notaires sahin cinq entrées est très
connu dans la natation d'attenté dit m
roxana maracineanu accord avec anne
entretenu une relation quand elle était
mineure ah ouais d'accord voilà c'est
écrit dans un livre qui s'appelle
entraîneur et l'enfant il faut savoir
que dans le sport ya un enfant sur sept
qui est victime d'abus sexuels ou de
prédateurs donc je pense que c'est un
malheureusement un drame qui va hanter
la boîte de pandore rôle exactement ça
avec la booth et d'autres d'autres alors
yannick hamel il a une personnalité
très particulière il est très seul dans
le milieu de la natation même s'il était
consultant on a enquêté avec les équipes
samedi avait des championnats de france
d'hiver de natation on ne peut pas dire
que
cette histoire là et déclenché une
immense surprise mais c'est à dire qu'on
cette relation là
certains là que je pèse mes mots
certains la connaissaient ils pensaient
que c'était consenti les savait qu'ils
avaient eu ça à l'époque et aujourd'hui
pour le moment ça peut changer mais il
ya assez peu de soutien pour yannick
agnel
qui a une une personnalité qui est
devenu très particulière après la mort
de vous souvenez de la nageuse camille
landais récemment télévision accident
d'hélicoptère l'émission d'europe il a
considéré comme sa grande soeur c'est en
2015 et à ce moment là sa personnalité
vassy et s'enferme dans une sorte de
deux solitudes un peu spirituel et plus
personne là ma maîtrise et qui il était
il est devenu très particulier et en
2016 par dont beaucoup de nageurs me
disent que il savait qu'il entretenait
une relation ensemble quelle est la
chasse gardée des régions s'il a reconnu
les faits il fallait obligatoirement en
prison m alors oui c'est pas si
toutefois il ya vraiment violent et donc
crime c'est pas parce que reconnaissons
crime qu'on va pas en prison donc
effectivement c'est quand même assez mal
barré ce qu'il faut quand même savoir
c'est qu'il encourt vingt ans de prison
faut commander quelque chose c'est que
le viol c'est 15 ans de prison mais à
des conditions qui font qu'on a une
peine supérieure parce qu'à des
circonstances aggravantes il y en a
trois la première c'est quand on a
autorité sur la personne qu'on a violé
donc on va un enseignant sur son élève
d'accord la deuxième c'est quand c'est
un mineur de moins de 15 ans dont c'est
le cas de cette affaire est la troisième
je voudrais dire ici c'est important
c'est lorsque vous êtes mariés si votre
conjoint ne veut pas de relation faut
savoir que le viol entre conjoints
existe je suis donc ce n'est pas parce
que c'est votre épouse votre conjoint ce
que moi tu fais des divorces du pétrel
anthony swarm et aux anneaux vous
comprenez ben moi elle n'a pas voulu
mais c'est ma femme il faut qu'elle
accepte si vous forcez votre conjoint
non seulement c'est un viol mais c'est
un viol puni encore plus sévèrement ce
que là aussi ses 20 ans de prison bon
faut bien rappeler que le viol entre
conjoints existe aussi c'est
malheureusement très courant